Ultimately, as we try to
find the maximum flow,
we're going to start with
a suboptimal flow and
then augment it with a flow we
find in the residual network.
Let's see how this works.
We'll start with
the flow f in a graph G.
And then drawing the residual network,
we'll let f' be a flow over this graph.
Of course, it obeys the residual
capacity constraint.
Then we add these two flows together
using a special definition.
Note only one of these two
values of f' can be positive.
Now I claim without proof
that this augmented flow
is a flow in our original network G, and
that its value is just the sum of
the two values of the individual flows.
This is pretty easy to verify
with the equations, but
it's not very illuminating.
So we'll skip it here and
focus on the intuition instead.
Is this augmented flow a flow
in the original network G?
It fits within the capacity constraints
essentially by construction of
the residual capacities.
And it conserves flow,
because both f and f' do.
So yes.
And the flow out from
the source is a simple sum,
which makes it a linear function.
So yes,
it makes sense that the flow of the sum
should be the sum of the flow values.